إذا كنت ترغب في القيام برحلة برية جيدًا ،
فستخطط لهذا العام أكثر من
السنوات الماضية ، وهذا بالتأكيد هو أول
نقطة اتخاذ قرار القيادة مقابل الطيران
وفقًا لصديقي د.  بريتي ميلاني
إذا كنت بحاجة إلى البقاء في فندق لأكثر
من ليلة ، فمن المحتمل أن ترغب في
السفر بدلاً من الجفاف وتذكر أن
القيادة توفر لك الكثير من
المرونة والكثير من
التحكم في حقائبك الخاصة
يمكن أن يضطر الأشخاص الآخرون إلى لمس تلك الأشياء التي
تتحكم فيها في الأشخاص الذين
تتواصل معهم ، ويمكنك تناول
طعامك ومياهك أيضًا ، كما أنه يقلل من
عدد مرات التوقف ، شيء واحد تريد أيضًا
أن تنظر إليه هو المكان  هل ستذهب
هناك بعض الولايات مثل مين ونيو
مكسيكو ، على سبيل المثال ، كانت لديها
أوامر الحجر الصحي هذه عند وصولك
إلى هناك ، يجب أن تكون في
الحجر الصحي لمدة 14 يومًا ، لذا عليك أن
تأخذ ذلك في الاعتبار أيضًا ، كما تعلم ،
أعتقد أن معظم الناس الآن  عندما يسافرون إلى
مستوى مع نوع من عدم التعبئة ، فهذا
هو ملكنا ، فلدينا مناديل مبللة لليدين هنا ،
لديك أقنعة ، لديك قفازات ، لديك بعض
المطهرات اليدوية ، وهذا هو
ما يمكنك فعله بالتأكيد
لجعله مزيجًا
من البورسلين الشمالي.  أونا تنقل
هذا الفيروس لا يوجد سبب
لعدم اتخاذ احتياطات معينة بقدر
ما إذا
كنت تسافر مع أفراد عائلتك في
الغالب ، فربما لا تحتاج إلى
ارتداء أقنعة إذا كان هناك أشخاص آخرون
في السيارة  قد تحتاج إلى ارتداء الأقنعة أيضًا
قدر الإمكان على الرغم من أن الجو حار
بالخارج حاول إبقاء النوافذ مفتوحة حوالي
ثلاث بوصات والنوافذ مغلقة ، حيث
تتراكم حوالي 10 أضعاف الفيروس
داخل مقصورة السيارة الآن أخيرًا
ماذا عن الحيوانات الأليفة ، فلا بأس بذلك  أحضر صالونًا للحيوانات الأليفة ،
نعم حقًا ، نعم ، وجود جليسات للحيوانات الأليفة أو
جليسات المنزل في السيارة وتريد
محاولة تقليل المخاطر بقدر
الإمكان ،
حظًا سعيدًا ، ابق بأمانًا ، واستمتع بصيف رائع
[موسيقى]